queremos sumar 19 y 318 a vos más 18 y
dos tercios
entonces lo primero que hago yo es
dividir
estos números mixtos en su parte entera
más su fracción así es que tenemos 19
más 3 18 a vos más 18 nada dos tercios
ahora lo siguiente que hago yo siempre
es sumar primero los enteros y después
las fracciones entonces para sumar los
enteros tenemos que sumar 1919 más
el siguiente entero que es 18 18 y esos
son todos los enteros que veo por aquí
entonces ahora vamos a sumar las
fracciones vamos a sumar 318 abós 318 a
vos nadas dos tercios
las dos tercios ahora para sumar 318 a
vos más dos tercios lo que tenemos que
hacer es encontrar el denominador común
pero el denominador común es 18 porque 3
por 6 18 entonces el mínimo común
múltiplo entre 18 y 36 18 entonces lo
que tenemos que hacer es convertir dos
tercios en una fracción cuyo denominador
sea 18 y como hacemos eso pues como 3
por 6 es 18 3 por 6 18 entonces lo único
que tenemos que hacer es multiplicar el
2 por 6 lo cual es 12 para obtener una
fracción equivalente a dos tercios pero
con denominador 18 entonces dos tercios
es equivalente a 12 18 a bosch y eso sí
ya es fácil de sumar así es que hagamos
la suma ya 19 + 18 son 37 37 y a esto le
sumamos 3 18 a vos +12 18 a vos o sea
que nos va a quedar una fracción cuyo
denominador sean 18
y 312 son 15
y esto 37 15 18 a vos es el número mixto
37 y 15 18 a vos muy bien esta es la
cantidad correcta sin embargo esta
fracción se puede simplificar así es que
hay que simplificar la 15 es divisible
entre 3 y 18 es divisible entre 3
así es que dividimos el denominador y el
numerador entre 3 y eso lo que nos da
son 37 enteros y 15 entre 35 entre 18
entre 3 son 6
así es que 19 y 318 abós + 18 y 2
tercios es igual a 37 y 5 sextos